مرور المياه هو مشروع
بالتعاون مع الفنان يون كانغ
وشريكتنا وكالة ناسا وهو مشروع عبارة عن
عمل فني يهدف إلى سرد
قصة توفر المياه العذبة
من خلال بيانات الأقمار الصناعية من وكالة ناسا
ثم سردها من خلال سرد القصص
والمرئيات التي تهدف في الأساس  للمس
الجمهور الأوسع ولكن كل مستوى من مستويات
المجتمع جلب المياه العذبة
كموضوع داخل الشرطة هو أيضًا وسيلة
لربط المحادثات التي تحدث
خلف الأبواب المغلقة وكذلك
الجمهور الأوسع وما يمر به الناس حقًا
في
العالم الحقيقي عندما تأتي  داخل
التجربة، توجد غرفة مظلمة كبيرة بها
رسم خرائط للعرض، وتخطو على
منصة تحتوي على صور جميلة
وتتفاعل مع الآخرين في المشروع
ويأخذك العمل الفني عبر ثلاثة
أجزاء مختلفة، وتدور المقدمة حول
ميزانية المياه ومقدار ما نحتاجه بالفعل
لدينا على الأرض وأه لم أكن أعلم حتى
هذا المشروع ولكن اه الأرض مكونة
من 71% من الماء لكن 3 3.5% فقط من
تلك المياه هي في الواقع مياه عذبة
يمكننا استخدامها ثم يتم نقلك إلى
بيانات الأقمار الصناعية وبيانات الأقمار الصناعية
توضح لك مقدار المياه التي
فقدناها مقابل مقدار ما اكتسبناه وبالتالي
مقدار دورة المياه التي
تضررت دورة الهيدرولوجيا بسبب تغير المناخ
وكذلك الإفراط في الاستخدام من قبل النشاط البشري
ثم ننظر إلى الحلول  لأننا
لا نستطيع التوقف عند هذا الحد، نحتاج أيضًا إلى جلب
الأمل، رؤيتي الفنية هي ترجمة
البيانات لأن البيانات لا تتحدث عن
نفسها ولكن ربما يمكن للفن أن يساعد في القيام بذلك،
ما أردت فعله حقًا هو
جعلها قابلة للتواصل، لذا هذا  السبب
الذي جعلني أجعله
ملاحيًا بالكامل، يمكن للأشخاص تصغيره وتصغيره
مثل تحريكه والاحتفاظ به حتى يشعر
الناس به ويفهمونه،
وهذا ما فعلناه
بمياهنا العذبة هذه الشراكة مع Google
حقًا  يركز على قمرين صناعيين، أحدهما
هو النعمة والنعمة التي تقع على مجموعة من
الأقمار الصناعية، وهي اختصارات طويلة
نحب اختصاراتنا في وكالة ناسا، لكنهم
كانوا يقيسون منذ حوالي عقدين من الزمن والآن
يجمعون معلومات حول المياه،
وأحدث واحد لدينا هو تضاريس فكرة المياه السطحية  لقد
تم جمع القمر الصناعي أو SWAT
لمدة عام تقريبًا، لذا
أطلقنا في 16 ديسمبر من
العام الماضي وكانت هذه البيانات مستمرة،
ونحن مستمرون في جمعها
لمراقبة كيفية تحرك المياه حول
العالم بهذا النوع من التثبيت وهذه
الشراكة هي  من القوي جدًا مجرد رؤية
البيانات وتقديمها
بطريقة يسهل الوصول إليها وذات معنى
للأشخاص، وهو أمر
يصعب جدًا القيام به كعالم، فأنا دائمًا ما أواجه
صعوبة في ذلك، كيف أجعل
الناس يفهمون ما نريده حقًا؟  نحن نقوم بذلك
ولكن أعتقد أن فرصًا مثل هذه والطريقة
التي يتم بها تصورها هي حقًا
[موسيقى]
مؤثرة